K World okay so uh what did we learn in
the first couple hours uh we learned
what a random measure is it's a
stochastic process index by collection
of subsets we learned a particular way
to construct a random measure with stick
breaking um a recursive scheme um more
generally one talks about size bias
sampling um stick breaking is a
particular example of that um and then
we learned there's various
marginalizations where you get rid of
some of the underlying probability
structure and things see combinatorics
the Chinese restaurant process is a
combinatorial object of distribution on
on uh
partitions um okay so let's see a little
bit more of the connections I want to do
one kind of last one um uh so I had this
diagram here that kind of organizes our
thinking we have these random measures
that are formed as sums of
atoms and um we learned how to get
things like POA and um um Chinese
restaurant process out of that and then
we're going to be going up to complet
random measures here um so one more
connection then is perhaps what if I
were to start with POA is there a way to
kind of to get to the stick breaking
perspective we kind of went the other
way around um and so uh so there is um
so um let's remember the Chinese
restaurant process I've got people
coming in and sitting at these tables
and so
on um so let's imagine a um a special
case of a poli ear um where uh uh you
only have two binary po you have two two
values okay so a one is going to mean
that you sit at the first table in the
Chinese restaurant and a zero is going
to mean you sit at any other table we're
going to binarize this situation okay so
the first person sits here with
probability one so let's forget about
that all right so let's think about the
second person on okay okay second person
on um so second person sits here or or
not and um so let's let Z be indicators
denoting um from the second person on
okay which whether you sit at the first
table or not those two possibilities
okay and let's consider the probability
that everybody sits at the first table
so Z1 is equal to one Z2 is equal to one
dot dot dot uh ZN is equal to one up to
some
n okay um
all right so that's just by our you know
calculations earlier um the Z1 sits
there with probably proportional to one
because there's already one person
sitting there the initial person uh and
then Alpha plus one and then two alpha
plus two you know dot dot dot up to n
Alpha plus
n okay and you don't have to know a lot
of combinatorics to know that that
numerator is gamma of n plus one and
then downstairs is just the uh
increasing
factorial there's a little formula then
for the particular
probability nus one
um okay I've got n plus one in my notes
well why do I want well the last person
there's only I got n uh so there's a
first person who sat there determined
I've forgotten about them and this is
everybody the second on so but I've
indexed them from one through n so
there's n plus one total people yeah
thank you so um so you look at that
object there and you say well um uh as a
function of n that you know I'm getting
some distribution here that kind of
looks like a moment okay it looks like a
moment of some kind so what what moments
are those so if now if you return to
defanti so let's remember defanti was
for any exchangeable sequence um I get
this integral expression so let's take
the exchangeable sequence of these
indicators it's a polar earn so they're
they're certainly exchangeable and so by
defanti the probability that the
changeable sequence takes on particular
values I wrote that earlier as Theta n a
that it'll be Z is equal to a one or a
zero those are the only possibilities in
the berly case so I can write this um
well that's equal to and then I had a
product of the G of AI well AI can only
take on two values you're either a zero
or one right so that g entity is really
just a single number the probability
that you're one or probability you're
zero let's call that probability Ada so
it's the probability of coming up heads
that IE that you saw at the first table
and so and now I'm saying that everybody
sat at the first table so the
probability of that happening given Ada
is Ada to the
N okay so that's the G that's the
product the product became the the
exponent in because they're all the same
uh of the G's that's that's and the
binary case that's what you get and then
we have a distribution on the Ada so
let's just write that as um so we we'
put a distribution there on definity but
now we're trying to get a specific set
of moments so let's guess a particular
distribution there and see if we can
recover those moments so let's guess the
beta okay um so uh here's our guess I
just put in the beta I'm going to write
it as beta there's a normalizing
constant which I'm going to call
normally it's alpha 1 Alpha 2 but we
kind of know where we're heading I'm
going to put a one comma bet Alpha in
there I'm going to use a particular beta
distribution because we have reasons to
believe that beta 1 comma Alpha is the
right thing to use here so I'll use it
here and so beta distribution remember
it's you know um well it's just uh
uh you know Ada to the one minus one
power zero so I get a one that goes away
I just get the second term the one minus
Ada to the alpha minus one power and
da okay so that's suggested by defanti
with a particular guess for what the
defanti mixing measure might be okay and
now you don't have to do do a lot of
know a lot of calculus to you remember
that's a that's a gamma you know it's a
ratio of gamas you plug it in and you do
this little integral and you get out
exactly the
this okay so this distribution here has
a name it's called the beta buruli it's
a distribution and it's gotten by taking
the beri distribution and mixing it
across an underly beta it's called the
beta beri it has certain heavier
Tails um you know because of the mixing
then you would get out of a pure beri
and that makes sense because a pure beri
is that I told you the coin tossing
probability was3 or 0. five here we're
randomizing over the coin and getting a
bunch of ones and zero so obviously we
get more spread heavier tails
okay so uh you know this is equal and
that's a calculation you can
do okay so um we have a uh um um a
random variable that has uh you know
random what's random here is is Ada and
I chose a particular density for it so
this is the inth moment of ADA just the
expectation of ADA to the nth power
that's the nth moment right and I saying
I know all the moments they all have
this form so if I know all the moments
are Rand varable I know the random
variable and so this random variable
here has as its moments this this uh you
know beta RI okay so that tells you that
the probability of sitting at the first
table or not is given by drawing from a
beta 1 comma
Alpha okay so that says that the
probability associated with this thing
is beta 1 comma
Alpha all right so that's the probity
sitting at the first table or not all
right now let's take all the people that
sat at the first table and forget about
them all right and now think about the
second table so there was some first
person who sat at the second table
forget about that person and think about
all the subsequent people either they
sit at the second table or they
don't okay so the remaining probability
we forgotten about this table that had a
certain probability beta 1 comma Alpha
forget about that break off the stick
the remaining probability we're going to
allocate either the city in the second
table or not and now the exact same
argument goes through that that's a beta
1 comma Alpha
distribution right and so that breaks
off another part of the stick to allow
you to this table and then we get beta 1
comma alpha beta 1 comma Alpha so we get
stick breaking out of this
argument okay all so's a little bit of
sloppiness here about size by sampling
and ordering issues but I'm I'm that
basically is is kind of the argument
okay so we're doing the moments and now
you actually know how to work with some
of the moments of these things that if
you like methods of moments um you know
these are the moments you would work
with if you would like to set them to
empirical moments that would be
interesting thing to
do okay so that's what I want to say
about
that um okay so uh next step is what I
want to focus most of my time on which
is this other Arrow here so let's say
that we've now learn to construct a
whole variety of these things with say
heavier tails and other properties and
we're starting to get a little zoo of um
of ways to choose these processes can we
can we organize that Zoo a little bit
better um okay
so um why is this object called a derish
process okay so um we've used that name
but we never the dis distribution
appeared at some point but just once
okay and all this other G stuff there's
no derish sitting in there there's a
sequence to Beta so Tam I gave you some
clue but now here's a much more direct
way to think about it so here's this
underlying space on which all the atoms
are living with their weights so let's
carve up that space into regions A1 A2
you know dot dot dot up to AK so let's
take a partition of the underlined
space okay we're putting a random
measure on the space and I was drawing
it you know with these little picket
fence kind of diagrams earlier now we're
in this two-dimensional setting but
anyway it's a bunch of atoms at certain
locations with certain Heights given by
the GM process so that's a particular
realization if I do that again and again
I'll get a random variable associated
with each of these K regions so in fact
now I have a random vector ga1 ga2
2 dot dot dot g a that's just a
collection of random values uh random
variables so it's a random Vector the
infinity has gone
away all right and so um I assert that
this has this random Vector has a
distribution all right um so these G's
um will all add up to
one okay because this object we got out
of GM was a random not just a random
measure it was a random probability
measure okay so this up to one um and
they add up to one and they're non-
negative H what distribution I know does
that well so this in fact is coming from
a derish distribution derish
distribution had parameters alpha 1
Alpha 2 up to Alpha K as Tamara was
showing you where the where's the
Alpha's coming from this problem well
they are exactly um the alpha literal
parameter from the stick breaking times
the G measure evaluated on the set so
that just gives you a number and that
scales it up
all right and then I get Alpha G A2 dot
dot dot Alpha G A K so those are just
numbers and you put them into a derish
and they diverse some numbers which are
random and those are the marginal
probabilities under the diset process so
derish process has derish
marginals right and again the stochastic
process here is indexed by by sets these
are particular sets so we're talking
about marginals of the derly process
literally okay so I'm going to prove
this as a consequence of what we've been
doing um it turns out the very first
paper about the dis process 1971 Circa
this was the
definition okay it was an and they Ed
korov argument so it said uh assert that
these are the finite dimensional
distributions uh therefore by kagar
there exists underlining process which
we will call the derish process but it
was very non-constructive and in fact it
wasn't quite right it wasn't this thing
didn't actually quite satisfy the kog gr
conditions
but that was the original paper how did
you get just partitioned I partitioned
some arbitrary way and the definition is
is that if this holds for all
partitions then I have by definition in
the old days a derate process I'm going
to show that if you partition this in
any way that this follows from our gem
dis process what the G or what is it dis
process is the underlying stochastic
process which has these things as
marginals
it's some yeah it's indexed by
collections of sets and if you look at
particular sets they have a particular
distribution and that's the joint of
those is
disle yeah but if you start with that
definition how do you actually show that
there is a process which satisfies
korov so korov had a very I just have a
bunch of consistent uh finite
dimensional distributions plus a certain
topological
constraint okay and this has consistent
marginals that's property the
distribution if I Collapse two of the
cells a k and a minus one these will add
and so they they'll be consistent um but
it's this topological property that
actually didn't work out for this
process the first paper didn't get that
quite right um so later papers did this
GM construction and that's clearly
rigorous you just need countably
infinite number of pi variables and F
variables that's that's clearly defines
the stochastic process and then to show
that it had toally marginals is not so
hard so that's a different way of
getting
all right so
um okay so let's try to uh what I'm
really going to try to do now is is
Define another object called a gamma
process and um once you see how to
define a gamma process you'll see Define
all kinds of other stochastic processes
and they have all combinatorial sides to
them there's a whole zoo of
combinatorics that will come out and
you'll start to see some of that um so
why are we going to Define an object
called a gamma process well um you all
know what a gamma random variable is
it's kind of the statistical physics
random variable it goes up at some
polinomial rate and then it decays
exponentially entropy versus energy um
so uh that's one gamma random variable
if I have a collection of K Rand gamma
random variables I'm going to have K
numbers that are all non- negative they
will not sum to one but they will sum to
something finite so divide and normalize
those K random variables and I get the
derish way okay so that's an easy little
calculation if you've ever seen that uh
it's actually in some sense a definition
of the dis take independent gamas sum
them up um divide you get something that
sums to one and that that is the derish
um so if you want to get the derish
actual density function that's the way
to get
it um okay so uh we might imagine then
on a space like this that we could
Define an object called a gamma process
which has gamma
marginals okay IE if we look at any some
other process let's not call it g if I
look at you know h h of A1 h of A2 and H
of a I would get a bunch of gamas and
they would be independent and if I can
do that for any choice of A's then I've
defined a gamma process uh and then when
I divide I will get a der process okay
so how do we Define a gamma
process all right
um
okay so let's define a completely random
measure now so we're going to go right
up to here um and talk about this object
called a completely random measure very
natural if you're a computer
scientist so um let's do this in one
dimension so I can make my prettier
drawing so here's one of our Picket
Fences we've drawn um a G from some
thing and not necessarily derish process
anymore just some arbitrary thing blah
blah blah okay so and now this so this
is now the space Theta it's a
onedimensional so let's divide it up
into regions you know here's A1 A2 and
let's make it a partition we didn't have
to in general but let's make it a
partition A3 dot dot
dot okay so now for each one of these um
regions there'll be a certain random
amount of mass falling into them under
the stochastic process for G so G of AI
is in fact a random variable we talked
about that before
all right so now in general if you look
at G Ai and G AJ those are two random
variables will they be dependent
independent well either and under the
derish process are they independent or
dependent they're dependent right
because they have to sum to one so they
have a negative correlation so if this
is really big because I have to sum some
to one this will typically be smaller a
negative
correlation but it's kind of a weak
negative correlation so you could
imagine an interesting definition would
be let's define a stochastic process
such that these are all independent of
each other for all I and J okay so the
amount of mass that drops in here and
here and here it's all independent so
why would you want that well because now
if you're thinking about divide and
conquer algorithms if you've got
independence in the PRI you can break
the problem up on different processors
and they can go about their aasian
analysis merly and put it all back
together so if your computer scientist
you know this would be a very natural
first step is toine random measures
which have are completely random
CRM okay so you know what a random
measure is it's a stochastic process on
a sigma algebra and now you know what
completely means it just means for any
partition I have
Independence all right so did there
exist interesting completely random
measures yeah tons of them so we're
going to start to to characterize them
okay so the first completely random
measure you need to learn about is
something called the pon random
measure Pon random measure
all right so everybody probably knows
what a plusone point process
is right um so what's plus one point
process okay not doing good board I keep
jumping around but here's some space
Theta and um a pone Point process just
drops it's a set valued stochastic
process it just drops points in the
space okay and it does it in such a way
that if you take any little cell here
and you ask about the the number of
points in that thing that number is a
pone random variable okay now the
homogeneous Pome process there's a
constant rate over the entire space and
so the pon I eventually get out has a
constant rate Lambda uh which would be
Lambda of it actually be a a measure it'
be Lambda let's call it mu that's what
I'm be calling it later mu of if this is
a little subset a it' be this the
measure the little bag measure of a so
the volume of a I get more plusone
counts as I get a bigger volume all
right but the counts are plusone okay
and so I think all of you know how to
construct these things one way to do it
is to pick a total number of points out
of a Pon call it n and then given that
throw them
uniformly at random over the space so
that's a homogeneous paone process so
what's a non-homogeneous pawon process
all right well that's one where you have
a this this mu function um is not
constant it can vary over the space okay
so I might have something kind of tilts
in this direction where I have a bigger
raate over here and a smaller raate over
here so then I would take I would
integrate mu um you know DX over the set
a where this is some rate function and
I'd get a number that's an integral over
over the set of a function and that but
that would now just give me a number and
then I put that into a plusone
distribution and that would deliver a
count associated with that region and if
my function is bigger in some regions
I'll tend to get more counts so this is
lots of real life data like this there's
lots of clustering over here is a city
here's this is the urban area I would do
that with non homogenous
Plus okay so uh that's a plus Point
process what's a plus random measure
well it's a different mathematical
object a plus Point process stochastic
process on sets set valued process each
realization is a set of points plus
random measure a realization is a random
measure it's a measure right but it's
easy to convert so if we do this in one
dimension I could have a plus Point
process maybe not
homogeneous which just gives me some x's
right and it's all I need to do is to
put a Delta function above each one of
them height
one and I get a Plus on random measure
so it's just essentially the same
mathematical object but it's it's it's a
measure instead of a set valued function
okay so if you were to write it you
would write G is equal to sum of Delta
functions at locations FK where these
are chosen uniformly
random or according to a rate function
mu to make it cluster and I'd sum that
up k equal 0 Infinity all I'm missing is
the weights there because they're all
set to one
okay so that's a plusone random
measure one of my favorite books in
probability by the way some of the
students in the room a Sinar Shin at um
Princeton has a very nice book called
probability and stochastics instead of
using the kind of you know gaussian
focused probability story that most
books do this is the pon focused
probability story and pone random
measures play an incredibly important
role in that book um you define brownie
emotions in terms of them and so on and
I think this is the way to think about
probability in the F teaching text in
the future is that's I really like this
is Aon simar's book probability in
stochastics yeah um so for the random
measures so the points are fixed and
it's just the like kind of the weightage
that you're these are random so these
are chosen uh either out of the uniform
if you're doing the homogeneous or out
of non-uniformly and given those have
been chosen these are all random the
these weights are fixed at one instead
of being by the GM process okay so as I
keep drawing from this I'm getting
different configurations but it's it's a
measure because if I hit you know if I
do I can do talk about G of a I just hit
a Delta of
a that'll be a 01 L okay never number
points falling in some
set okay um so is a pone random measure
a completely random measure yeah yeah
it's a theorem but it's a kind of
trivial theorem if I partition this
space up and I ask how many points fall
in each region well it's Pon all right
and it's independent that's a property
the Pome process in fact it's a
characterization of the Pome process the
only counting process that has that
property okay so if I really was
insisting on completing random measures
it's a characterization to have
Independence how can I get beyond the
pone all right so now you get this
really amazing
construction to Kingman and Levy and
other thing that's
probabilists all right so let me get the
good notation here
this comes out
nicely um actually just to a little more
notation here I'm going to be calling
Pon random measures with an N instead of
a g so let's get rid of that a there so
that'll be n it's a it's a n will be the
symbol for a random measure that has
atoms of f weight one okay um and so n
of a is a random variable which is
indeed a pon
um with some rate which will be some
measure mu of
a that's just that's my notation okay so
now crms complete the random measures so
what we're going to first do is um form
a product space so we're going to take
our underline space we're trying to put
a random measure on and we're going to
cross that with the reals plus so here's
the diagram if this is the Theta space
I'm going to add another dimension to my
problem which is the reals the positive
reals not negative real
so I got a two- dimensional space now
not a one you know so if this weren't
one dimension If This Were a function
space for example fine you just add one
dimension to your function space I just
can't draw
it okay all right now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to put a nonhomogeneous
pone process on the product space so I'm
going to throw down uh some points on
this thing so um you know here they are
maybe and it's non homogeneous so I'm
now going to try to make a drawing here
so here's maybe a rate function might
look something like
this bad drawer but over that product
space there's a function which if I
integrate it I get a number for any
given little region okay so this
particular I had tilting up like that so
I'm going get more and more points down
here it'll be denser down here because
there's a bigger rate okay all right so
from a the pone process with a so I'm
going to define a um a rate mu um which
is a rate it's a measure on um R and I'm
going to make that itself be a product
measure so it'll have a Theta component
which I'll call G and it'll be crossed
with a component in that direction which
is called the levy measure I'm going to
call that ADA so this is the levy
measure and this is some arbitrary rate
you put there which is the same symbol
we've been using for for the same
reasons and it's kind of a degree of
freedom for you as a probabilist or
statistician and I'm making this product
measure on this space this function I've
drawn be a um be a product it didn't
have to be in this general theory you
you don't have to have it be a product
but I'm treating this axis and this axis
separately okay so um right so if I were
to you know just apply this to a little
rectangle uh set here you know that I
would have mu of let's call it a cross
e so that would be just G of a times um
Ada of e okay just a definition of a
product
measure Okay so from this um this pone
Point process or random measure on this
space I get a bunch of atoms so
Pon
PRM generates a whole infinite
collection of atoms when I sample from
it actually it wouldn't have to be
infinite but um it's going to be
infinite because this thing is going to
be infinite um so what names do I give
to those atoms they have two
coordinates so let's call them Fe and W
we get a whole collection Fe um w so the
Fe I might get a you know F1 here and a
W1 here so my first point I draw and the
plus random measure is sitting right
there has coordinates Fe and W and then
I start getting a whole bunch of them so
I have a whole collection of uh two
valued um uh vectors here so that that's
that's these X's that I'm drawing all
right and now what I'm going to do is
this is the key part of the construction
I'm going to drop a line from these
points down to this axxis and put little
arrows there if you will and now having
doing so I will be putting a random
measure on this space and I'll forget
the rest of the diagram so I'll go back
to my Theta space so to Define that I
will now Define a random measure G um
equals to um well what do this mean it
means that I have an atom a Delta
function at location
Fe and it's weighted by the height which
is a w value the corresponding W value k
equals 1 to
Infinity okay everybody see that from
Pome Point process I get a bunch of
points spread around the space it has
two coordinates all right this the first
coordinate defines the location and I
put an atom there and the second
coordinate defines the height I put a w
there and so I literally get this yeah
uh I could use some intuition of where
this is going so with the previous one
there was this clustering intuition so
what is what phenomenon is this yeah so
um I I think just trust me a little bit
longer that the math is going to lead us
somewhere um I I can say the following
that Tamar's going to get into a lot of
applications to random graphs and power
laws and graphs and all that and this
will flow exactly out of this also we're
she may we'll talk about feature models
at some point so um what one thing
that's broken by the Chinese restaurant
process for lots of applications is you
come and you have to sit at one
table right um many of us want to sit at
multiple tables all right in particular
what if the tables are uh not clusters
they're like features so the first one
would be what language you speak the
second one would be what kind of food
you like what kind of exercise you like
well I come in you know I speak English
and Italian um you know I like these
kinds of foods so there's a whole
checkbook a little bit Vector for
everybody that's called a feature model
dally process doesn't deliver that it
wants you to sit at one table something
else called the beta process does
deliver that it allows you to sit a
multiple tables and the beta process
will flow right out of this uh so
basically each one of these atoms in the
beta process will be a number between
this this space will actually end 0 to
one these will be an infinite collection
of
coins with numbers between 0 and one so
I draw redraw this diagram on the Theta
space I will be getting an infinite
collection of coins at certain locations
that are between zero and one you know
this might be 6.3 or
whatever I'll draw from this process to
get that object and then I will toss
those coins and get ones and zeros
that's called a Bui process and now I've
got a bit Vector for for one person and
then I could do that again from this
underlying object I'm getting a beta
beri in the process world I'm getting an
infinite Vector for everybody's
propensity to have a certain feature you
know Italian versus English and then
you'll actually speak English or Italian
when you do the
beri okay so it's again the defin store
where I draw an object we could call
this one G and then I'll follow it
further with another draw from that so
now
that Theta is the space you're defining
the feat so Theta is the feature space
yeah so Theta would be the feature space
this space would be um yeah the
attributes you can have rightbut right
so what this attribute here my does he
speak Italian or not okay and the
probability and this population of
people that's what I'm modeling with the
underlying probabilities is 6 so a
particular individual might speak it or
not so that person then after you draw
from this will have a one or zero there
but that feature is the Italian or not
feature it has a probability right and
then another feature could be likes
Chinese food or not and so on and I'll
so I'll end up getting out a bit
Vector right and this one of the magic
of things happening here is this bit
Vector will be infinite dimensional but
it'll only have a small and finite
number of ones so it'll be a sparse
Vector so here's how you get sparsity
and sparse dictionaries and the Bas
formalism is with this process so does
that help you a little more to kind of
give you indication of yeah um so this
is an object here which is a random
measure but it's not a random
probability measure it doesn't integrate
to one if if you make this integrate to
one then it's a Rand probability then
it's you want to kind of pick one of the
entries you like you're sampling from a
measure you'll get one entry that's the
Chinese restaurant process
where you sit at one table if you don't
make the thing sum to one you sit at
multiple tables all right and there's
many other applications to you know
survival probabilities and all kinds of
other things but I'm just okay so
hopefully that was helpful but anyway
trust me a little bit more on the math
for a second okay so we've made a
construction here um by this this this
and this and now we have this object
here which is clearly a random measure
it has atoms and they're all random
locations random Heights is it a
completely random measure under this
construction what's the definitional
completely R if I partition my uh space
here A1 A2 does the amount of mass
falling into those A's is that
independent for all choices of
A's
yes yes because because it's coming from
as pone process yeah because it's coming
from a it's not a pone process but it's
coming from dropping pone weights into
these things so you look at the amount
of mass that can fall into the region A1
one it's all the points that lie on that
stripe right well that stripe is
independent of the next stripe over you
have to do a little more math to make
this rigorous but it's easy yeah sry how
does Theta represent features okay Theta
is just some arbitrary feature space it
could be you know word embeddings if you
will it could be a vector space you
cting I draw it it's one dimensional
just like draw it but imagine it's a
vector space of some kind okay how does
this allow you to have two features two
features okay so um I was going to the
case where uh I then took a further draw
which was which was um uh
beri okay so I'm you're either going to
have the feature or not and the feature
what it means to be a feature is that
you're at a particular place in the
Theta
space no um okay so you can use the
feature different ways here I'm thinking
of the feature as the underlying
Vector okay so it's a it's a it's a um
um
so let's suppose I have the Italian
feature okay then I'm going to use that
I'm Amazon I know you're Italian now I'm
going to use that to make predictions
about what kind of books you like right
so that book buying
Vector is is the
feature is that that's
Theta that's that's a point in Theta
it's all of the things associated with
that that person that that kind of
person okay an Italian person say but if
features are distinct points how can you
have two of them at the same you can so
you put that into statisical model so I
I uh I told you this person speaks
Italian and he lives in Berkeley okay
those are two things he can be right now
in terms of his book buying behavior
that probably might means he buys some
books about Italian you know whatever
but he also simultaneously buys books
about
Berkeley right and those are two maybe
real valued vectors in this data space
so I would put those two vectors in some
way into a statistical model Amazon does
exactly this to give a
list of recommendations over certain
kinds of books that are both Italian and
and and Berkeley so I'm not putting this
person into a cluster where we just buy
books like everyone else in that cluster
that was Amazon's original model which
didn't scale the new model is that you
can belong to simultaneously multiple
clusters meaning that I got multiple
vectors for
you right now I could add them that
would be kind of a dumb thing to do but
you don't have to tal models allow you
to take those vectors and maybe switch
between the two or or whatever I think I
confused because I thought the person
like sta was like a draw from this
distribution but it's not no that's
these these spaces I'm calling them
Theta instead of X person's the data
that's would be the X these are the
parameters lighing up above that
determine the further statistical model
about the choices or whatever okay so
it's a little abstract but um hopefully
that
helps okay so um this construction
indeed gives you completely random Mees
I mean they're I.E they're independent
among the sets here's the remarkable
fact is that that is actually a
characterization this is the only way to
get completely random measures so it
seemed like an exotic construction with
this product space and this pone and all
that uh and what Kingman proved in a
famous paper 1967 a 10-page beautiful
paper is that this is actually if and
only if it's the only way to get
completely random measures sorry yeah if
you look at the projection of
Thea
homogeneous what do you mean by
projection of the Theta so you look at
only sets on
uh A1 to a partition over this axis yeah
and partitioning over this axis that's
right yeah and you look at the
probability of A1 by by all what that
means it's all the points that drop into
A1 weighted by their weight Plus on um
the count would be a Plus on right but
these these masses each one of it's
adding of these things now now have
these weights here okay right so yeah
it's not a it's not a it's not a real
it's a real number now it's not a yeah
so there's these weighted atoms falling
there I'm adding up the total weights
associated with those ATS that's a total
mass but it's independent among the
stripes so therefore it's completely
random and that amazing tax it goes the
other way so now if you believe this uh
at this point um then the whole problem
reduces to this specification of this
Levy measure that's what gives you the
different completed random measures it's
the the rate measure okay so the
statistici or problem says okay I'm in a
brand new problem I want to use
completely random measures my degree of
freedom is right there your hand outs up
first yeah is there any
in um yeah there is I think I don't want
to get into it if you uh Kingman has a
beautiful book on the pon process that's
a weekend read it's this little thin
book and it's just totally beautiful and
in there you will get that intuition but
you'll have to study you'll have to
think about it a little bit basically
there's many characterizations of the
pone process and there's a the most
beautiful one is the most spare one it
doesn't you're not making almost any
assumptions but it's pone and that's
same kind of intuition happens here
Independence and plus oneone are quite
closely Allied but this is not plus
oneone it's it's it's taken from a
plus is there another yeah so so in this
case M does have to factorize across
Theta and R or I factorized
here you don't have to do this for the
general theory I'm doing this to
simplify so you still get it yeah you
still get this that's right that's right
yeah okay so let me try to move on CU I
do want to get a little further so
um all right so um that theorem you can
it's 12 Pages you can read it it's it's
interesting and not that hard let's try
to use this for something let's define a
particular completely random measure we
haven't done that yet so let's um so to
do that we have to pick our G and our
Ada uh this let's just pick to be
uniform it doesn't change anything it
just changes where the atoms are and
that's not important to us it's really
the the the combinatorics of the heights
of these atoms that matters and that's
determined by the levy measure
Levy by the way was another Berkeley
famous person who was here for many many
years and he defined what called Lev
processes which are brownie motions plus
jumps high widely used in finance and he
was the origin of this sometimes what
we're doing is instead if we stred
ourselves to one dimension we would be
doing Levy processes we're allowing
ourselves to be an arbitrary function
space where these atoms live so we're
Beyond classical
Levy um so
um
gamma process so let's define now a very
important process in statistical physics
and in um genetics called the gamma
process so to Define these Pro it is an
example of a CRM all we have to tell you
is what is Ada so um why did I call it
suddenly start call meate
MU I'm going to call it Ada all right so
Ada is a no a me I'm okay good
good I see so let's call me has two
parts to it um so let's now we're going
to be talking about doing integrals so
let's uh write this in kind of
suggestive integral notation um the
first part is just G not so you know we
can integrate against d g not fine
what's the other part this is the
important part well it's going to be
Alpha * w-1 * eus beta W * DW so it has
a density there it is um it's not just
an arbitrary measure it's a it's a it
has a density relative to leag measure
so this this is the second component
right here the first component is
here right um all right so what is this
well this should look familiar to that
is the gamma form it's a polinomial
growth uh killed off by an exponential
tail all right now normally you would
have an alpha here to get a gamma
distribution and this thing would
integrate to you know a gamma function
that you normalize there is no Alpha
here it's a zero so this thing actually
integrates to Infinity
okay fine you can have a measure of a
space be infinite and in fact that's
exactly what you want if this was a
nonzero there then this thing would
integrate to fing finite the underlying
rate measure would have a total finite
mass and the number of atoms I would get
out would be
finite I don't want finite numbers of
atoms I'm getting infinite sums in this
whole formalism that's what timer was
talking about to get infinite sums I
need some part of the mass to generate
infinite numbers of atoms and that's
exactly where it's happening the missing
Alpha here is where it happens
okay so that's a well-defined you know
rate function happens to you know be
infinite if I go over the entire space
in the r Direction perfectly fine M
could you define it in words again
sorry in words again that okay I've just
done I I don't know if you're used to
this kind of notation not so used to it
I'm just when I have a measure why why
do you define measure so you can
integrate with Spectrum that's the whole
point of having measures right so when I
integrate with spect to a measure you
know I write something like you know if
I have a probability a measure P P um
and I want to integrate with respect to
it it doesn't necessarily have a density
so I would write that as you know some
function f ofx p DX or DPX however you
prefer it that's a general the bag
integral kind of way of writing it you
know so um this symbol doesn't really
mean anything there's no notion of
differential it just means that you
integrate with respect to P okay so when
I write a measure and I put a little DX
there I just says when you get ready to
do the integral you know you're going to
write it this way so when I get ready to
do an integral respect to this product
measure
you know I'm going to give you little
arguments here those are things I'll use
inside the integral as dummy variables
so I'm suggesting those dummy variables
here and I did that because this
particular this Ada part right here this
is Ada it's a measure um you know Ada of
DW this one is not just an arbitrary
measure it has structure it has a
density not all measures have a density
this one does there's it's density and
you can plot this density it looks like
you know
that right
actually doesn't look like that looks
like that has a singularity here because
of that so gamma is a special case or
process special case is General
formalism General formalism you put an
arbitrary thing here and an arbitrary
thing here this is not so important so
I'm just leaving as G I'm putting a
special Choice here
this and that defines the gamma process
because this is a gamma looking like
density that's why it's called the gamma
Pro that's one reason it's called the
gamma process but that's not the only
reason VES of posi so yeah what
sorry yeah over the whole reals this is
this is this is you know r+ here's the
W's not it's not going up to one like
the the beta process I alluded
to okay so um good so we now
um we our notation is going to be uh
we're going to draw from a gamma process
with parameters um Al Alpha Beta and G
KN um and that's going to deliver these
these pick a fence kind of objects but a
different kind than we were talking
about this morning and the construction
is literally the one I just went through
here once I told you g not and I told
you beta and I've told you Alpha this
whole measure is specified therefore
I've got this therefore I put it into
the plone process and I drop these
things down and add them up and I've got
to draw and I can do that again and
again and
again okay
so why are we doing this well you know
many reasons but um um so I argued
earlier to get to dially distribution
you can go through it by getting gamas I
if I get some some independent gamas and
normalize them I get the diset well I'm
telling you how to get independent gamas
now um because I have independence by
the completely Randomness property and
now all I got to show you is this weird
construction here gives me marginals
that are themselves individually gamma
so I need to now show you that g drawn
in this way applied to any particular
set is gamma those classical gamma out
of your Elementary textbooks with some
parameter A and
B okay to be specified right if I can do
that because they're independent I've
got an independent collection of gamas I
could normalize them and get and Define
a derish process right and then this
whole toolbox could be done to Define
all kinds of other objects that aren't
gam that aren't Gamma or derish and then
in fact there was a whole beastiary of
them negative binomial processes and
blah blah
blah okay so the last
part how do you show that something has
gamma
marginals all right
um start
racing okay so I I claim that a certain
random variable has a certain
distribution that this GA constructed in
this complicated way let's just now
called a not
AI it's a certain random
variable um that has a certain
distribution right well uh how do I
verify that something has a certified
something has a certain
distribution um well I could just try to
calculate bare hands that's impossible
here um or I can start checking its
moments okay and if its moments are
matching up to the ones I think they are
starting to look good and if I do the
whole collection of moments and they all
match up that's what I did before right
another way to do that all at once is to
do the generating function all right um
so you need the now you need a
mathematical tool which you may not may
not have required in your life but you
need to um is um how do you calculate
moment generating functions of
stochastic processes so you all know
about moment gener functions of random
variables uh what's the moment generary
function of a stochastic process well
that is called the Levi kenion
theorem um so Levi kenion the so uh we
probably run out of time but I'm
actually in some sense going to prove
the Levi kenion theorem here for you
it's not that hard and and it's really
worthy of knowing about it's a very it's
if you're problemist this is like you
know everything every day you use this
all the time so um so and and it will
deliver the fact that this marginal
distribution is
gamma okay so so maybe to work up to
this actually I think it will finish in
10 minutes so um you know if this random
variable is gamma you know the gamma
let's write down the gamma in general so
the gamma in general um let me use
another variable that's it's you know
there's a what beta to the alpha let's
not use beta b b a b to the a over gamma
a a a minus one Z to the minus b b b z
now what am I doing
e right there's the gamma density in
general um has two parameters you know
this is gamma
ab and the mean uh if this is you know
uh some random variable let's call it X
expectation of X is just equal to A over
B
and there's a variance formula which has
a squ and b squs in it I forget it okay
so you can just calculate Moments by
doing integrals against this density and
get all these things so in particular if
this object is actually gamma then its
expectation should be some a divided by
some B so let's see if we can calculate
the expectation of this right this is
already going to be
interesting um okay so what is g
OFA um well it's just the definition is
that I add up these weighted things VK I
apply that to
a all right um now I'm going to write
this in a nice way is if you're a
probabilist this is the first thing you
do you get rid of sums you write
integrals so I'm going to write this as
W * the indicator of a um C and then I'm
going to use my measure as my measure to
integrate against a counting measure
because when we use counting measures
for integrals you get sums so what
counting measure well that thing n that
I told you about the plus own thing so d
Theta
DW okay so what this says is that um you
just take this underlying Pon points in
the space all right and you add up in
the the Fe direction if you follow in
the set a so that gets all the points
that fall into the set a and then you
add up their weights under this plusone
thing um here okay so this is just this
is this a pone so its weights are all
one and I multiply it by W to get the
actual weight in the complete random
measure so this is just another way of
writing this this is a clean way to
write
this okay um so our um object that we're
trying to integrate here now more
abstractly it's just some function of F
of F and W integrated against a um
random uh a measure so we're doing real
stochastic processes now we're taking an
integral of a function against a random
measure so this whole object is just a
number for each n but n Is Random so
this is a random
variable okay
all right so even more abstractly to get
rid of the Fe and W let's just call
those together
s let just call S equal Fe and
W um and so now my integrals are I'm
forming are of the form some function of
s and then some
um some measure which is random so
there's the kind of object I'm trying to
work with for a particular choice of F
and a particular choice of
n okay so now um let's calculate so uh
now we're going to do real measure
Theory we're going to say can I get
formulas for this for the particular
choice of a PO random measure so we had
to do this over all FS so let's start
with the indicators of sets and then
let's add up the indicators of sets to
get step functions and then let's use
monotone convergence theorem to to wave
our hands okay so our first kind of f
thin would just be um f is of the form
uh just some constant c times an
indicator of a set c i okay so it on
some set C it takes the value C and it's
zero everywhere else that's a particular
F okay and so now if we just calculate
with that F the expectation of this
random variable so I have an expectation
of that random variable um it's just the
expectation of plugging in my C
indicator of
Cai N
D um that's just equal to uh integral of
an indicator is just a
probability okay and the C will come
outside of the expectation so I get C
expected value of um of what well it's
the um uh measure of the set C when I
indicate it you know I use a measure or
over an indicator I just get the measure
of the set C what is the measure of set
C it's just n of C because N is a random
measure so now I have the expectation of
this random variable but that's
pone okay so n of C is Pon with a rate
which is the underlying mu function so
this is C mu
C okay moving along let's now do it for
sums of
indicators um so F ofi of the form sum
of uh CJ indicator big CJ XI same story
had expectation of that integral right
here um whatever
this um all right so it's just
expectation of um I think I kind of just
skip steps you guys can do this kind of
algebra so um right
uh indicator so it's going to be the
expectation of a sum of um CJ
indicator
n
dxi sums will come outside um as is well
the
CJ um then I will have the same thing I
did before it'll be the expectation of n
of C Capital CJ and um that's then mu of
CJ so it's the sum of CJ mu of
CJ and that is just the the integral the
lblue integral um of um
uh
F under the measure
mu okay I'm just adding up the measure
of a set times the value of the set
that's just the definition of the
integral you know it's a remon integral
sorry what's F here it's uh uh this it's
a step function kind of
it's so what's me here sorry what's the
MU here um uh mu is the underline
whatever it is it's the underline um G
cross Ada and Ada C is a space
in what is is why don't we take this
offline okay I I I want to keep moving I
think um not to finish
um M's the it's the symbol I used before
of you know mu is G not cross a are you
helping thanks
um so look what happened and this is
quite cool we were trying to take this
is a random quantity here we're taking
an integral of a deterministic function
against a stochastic process if we want
its expectation we should just get a
number and the amazing thing is the way
you get the number is you take that same
integral of that same function against a
deterministic measure which is the rate
measure for n so you replaced n with
mu all right so that's pretty amazing so
now Levy kinchin which I'm not going to
actually derive but I can it's almost
the exact same steps I'm going to write
down the answer however
um leave it as an exercise for you to do
it okay so you know moment Jing
functions right we all know and love
them things like
that um so um how do we do that for
stochastic processes maybe we'll put a
minus there let's put a t because I'm
using T in this so let still a plus
transform so you know how do you do that
um well if that's just a random VAR you
know we don't all kinds of tools but
what if it's a stochastic process now
I've got e minus t integral of some
arbitrary
function of ND side that's the kind
that's the random variable I care about
I'm putting that random variable into a
ll transform setting all right so can I
do those kind of
calculations um all right so
um um so how do you do this you do
exactly what I did there you take take
start with f FS which are indicators of
particular sets you plug it in you do
little calculus then you do it with step
functions you plug it in and then you uh
we'll get an answer in fact I didn't say
this here but this is now true for
arbitrary F because of monoton
convergence
theorem okay so I would do the same
thing here and I'll let you go through
the steps really do encourage you to do
them you will get out the Levi kensin
theorem which is one of the Pinnacles of
uh classical probability Theory uh here
it
is
okay so this is a llao transform of a
object defined by integrating against
the underly stochastic process the kind
of thing we want to do is B against all
the time take an underline stochastic
process find an integral a marginal find
its
distribution okay so if we can do this
for all T and get an answer and compare
it to some known results and they're the
same by uniqueness of you know plus
transforms were done right and look at
this for a second what happened is it up
in this expression it was random and the
random is coming in here 's a random
measure so we getting a random integral
and what's happened here is that n's got
replaced by a mu so it becomes
deterministic and that's the rate
function of n but a little more
complicated instead of just having F we
get 1us t to the E minus t a little more
complicated so anybody know why that
happened
sorry is that a familiar is this
familiar to anybody this object right
here from something you work
on it's the MGF ofon okay so in this
calculation right here the fact that
this object is not just has an expected
value it has a distribution which is
pone has to come through somehow and it
comes through that you'll need the MGF
of the pon along the way and that's what
this is so you're integrating the MGF of
the pon all right so this is really cool
this is a simple integral that you can
do in many many situations and um so
again there's an interesting so now
let's go back to our and I won't I'll
close up in a couple minutes but let me
just um tell you where the next part of
the story goes um yeah so let's now
return to our Gan not our Gan our gamma
process so we now have this new this is
the Levi kensin
theorem um and so if we want to now go
back to this and now plug in a specific
stochastic process marginal you know
gamma process applied to a set a um you
know then remember my definition of that
um that is uh
expectation e
um I'm going to go and write it out so
it's an integral over the Theta part
because there's this a product space it
has two pieces and over the
reals um and then it has this 1 minus E
to the T minus t and then f for us is is
back in the gamma process was an
indicator function W Times the indicator
of a
fe
bang um and then G KN D Fe here's our
Ada part and then the uh um the specific
choice of the gamma
so bang
bang okay so I put in my little gamma
integral here and my G here that was a
print uh integrated against this thing
right here and that's that's exactly
what this is okay and now you stick in
right here exactly that you know thing I
wrote up before which is Alpha wus One e
the minus beta duh DW throw that in
there and now you have an integral that
you could give to an undergrad just an
integral okay Calculus class all right
and um I'm not going to so here here at
the core I'll me I'll skip a couple
steps and and here's what you get near
the end it becomes um Alpha G of a so
that's just a number no big deal and
here's the chord that you have to do 1us
e to Theus
tww integrated against wus
one uh e to the minus beta W
DW okay um I puzzled on a whole Airline
right across the Atlantic on how to do
that stupid integral and I couldn't get
onto Wikipedia and even when I got into
I couldn't find it all right and I
thought integration by parts I started
hitting with this everything I knew and
I couldn't get it to come out and it
turns out it's a special integral that
was studied in the 1800s by a bunch of
Italians they have a whole huge theory
about these kind of integrals and
they've very interesting properties and
so I've learned how to do them now and I
will challenge you to find it it's not
that hard but there's a trick as there
often is with integration you can do it
um so fun exercise over the break or
tonight and after you do that integral
amazing thing happens you get the result
beta over beta plus t to the alpha g a
power all
right my lecture ends here because that
I recognize as a problemist that is the
gener function of a gamma
distribution okay moment function of a
gamma distribution I wrote up the gamma
at some point is in general is B over a
plus b uh or no sorry B plus t to the a
power okay you can do that calculation
yourself so we've learned that we have a
gamma moment jine function therefore G
of a must be gamma they're independent
because it's completely random therefore
I can normalize them and I can get the
derish
process
okay all right so um you know that's a
bunch of calculations but you know you
learned about the levy kinchin theorem
and I hope you saw that there's a pretty
General interesting mathematical
structure here and the fact that this
structure inside of it has all the kind
of Chinese restaurant process and pull
you earn is really quite interesting and
amazing
and it can all be understood and
explained at some point as you start to
study this topic um you know so um all
right and now uh having we done that
we've done that for the gamma and if we
wanted to put in other uh sto design
other stochastic processes here's our
design tool we replace that with
something else so the beta has the
form uh the beta process has the form
you know wus one 1 - W to the a minus
one
DW um and now there's a whole huge
literature on other
choices okay um I'm going to stop there
um see if there I haven't heard
questions for a while because I've been
shutting them down so we have a couple
minutes for questions and we'll take a
break and then Tam's going to do the
last hour I'm going have to leave about
partway through because there's a job
talk to go to but um so if you want to
talk to me I'll be here in the Break um
and Tamara is going to go into random
graphs really exchangeability Edge
exchangeability vertex exchangeability
of graphs and so these themes will come
back in a in a kind of in some ways a
richer more concrete
context any
questions